ever since the turn of the millennium
we've seen a massive trend towards free
to use software games and apps
everything from facebook google and
youtube to robinhood clash of clans and
spotify these services have become
masters at alternative modes of
monetization whether that be collecting
data or serving ads from a macro
perspective these free services are
awesome as they have made access to
information and content easier and
cheaper than ever before and in some
cases it makes no sense to spend money
on these services for example if you
watch a random youtube video here and
there then it probably doesn't make
sense to buy youtube premium similarly
in some cases there may be some pride in
not spending any money maybe you want to
max out your clash of clans account
without gems or maybe you want to be a
default god on fortnite putting such
scenarios aside though if you spend any
amount of substantial time on these free
to use services i'd argue that the
sacrifices that you're making on privacy
time and the opportunity to be a
customer are far greater than any
monetary cost that you could have paid
instead and here's why
starting with the most obvious sacrifice
we're making with free services we have
the sacrifice of privacy nowadays user
data is one of the most valuable forms
of currency in the world and this data
can be exchanged for billions of dollars
we all know that big tech and especially
google collects loads of data on all of
us but have you ever looked into what
exactly this data is well security.org
did and here's what they found starting
with the reasonable data we have name
phone number payment information and
email address these are all basic data
that google would need to distinguish
between users and appropriately charge
each user for subscriptions that they
may have this is likely most of the data
they need to provide users with a great
experience but this is just the
beginning of the data collection moving
on google collects data on emails you
write and receive your stored videos and
photos your stored documents your stored
spreadsheets and your youtube comments
so basically everything you store with
them and everything you communicate
through them google has advanced machine
learning and ai algorithms that can comb
through your photos and emails which
allows them to understand your lifestyle
who you spend your time with and your
hobbies for example you might have a ton
of pictures of your dog in this case you
would be a prime target for dog food and
dog toy ads similarly maybe you have a
bunch of pictures at the beach this
would make you a prime target for
flights to beaches and luxury beachside
resorts anyway next up google also
collects in-detail data regarding how
exactly you're accessing their services
we've got ip address system activity
data about interactions between apps
browser type device type application
version number carrier name and
operating system in terms of location
we've got gps data sensor data and even
information about things near the device
you're using and i haven't even covered
this activity section which has another
dozen data points about your calls and
interaction history clearly google
collects data on basically all facets of
your life and this is the same case with
facebook and twitter but what does this
even lead to
well the answer is low roi for you and
google
advertisers aren't stupid they're not
gonna run marketing campaigns that
aren't profitable sure a startup might
do this to generate a base of users but
do you really think that apple or nvidia
or amd is gonna run unprofitable ads
no and given all the data google has
collected for them their marketing
campaigns are more effective than ever
before
this means that the average person will
end up spending way more money than they
ever need to and i'm not talking about
valuable services there's definitely
going to be people who get asked for
things like audible and skillshare and
they're going to get a subscription and
they're going to get a bunch of value
from the service
rather i'm talking about consumerism
buying a new phone that you don't need
or going on a vacation that you can't
afford now again if you're doing well
for yourself and making 200 or 300 000
per year this doesn't matter for you you
can afford to splurge on a new phone
every year and go on vacation regularly
but for the average american making 50
or 60 000 per year these are expenses
that simply don't need to be in their
lives it would be much smarter for them
to save and invest this money into a
house or an index fund and that might
have been what they would have done if
it wasn't for such effective marketing
now i'm not faulting companies for using
such advertising mediums as that simply
a brilliant business decision but from
the consumer side sure you didn't have
to spend money to use google however
your net roi is likely thousands of
dollars in the red
at the same time it's not like google is
making much money off of you
individually either last year google
pulled in a total of 210 billion dollars
from advertising this includes google
search youtube and all other sources of
google related advertising now that is
an absurd amount of revenue but you have
to consider that google also has an
absurd amount of customers literally
over half the world uses google with
their worldwide user account coming in
at 4.3 billion if we divide their
advertising revenue by their user
account we get just 48.72
per customer and that's revenue google's
net income margin sits at just under 30
percent meaning that less than 15 of
that is actually profit now the real
numbers are likely much more skewed
there are likely billions of users that
only profit google one or two dollars
per year and there's likely billions who
profit them 50 or 60 per year but i
think you get the point google isn't
making hundreds or thousands of dollars
from each customer but by collecting
data a lot of their users end up
spending thousands of dollars that they
don't need to be spending so wouldn't it
be a lot better if we cut out
advertisers and directly paid google
what if we paid google 20 per month for
all of their services that's 240 per
year but in return we get an ad free
data collection free private experience
across all google services
not only would that provide a far
superior user experience but it would
save the average person thousands of
dollars in unnecessary spending in the
meantime since google doesn't have to
spend money on appealing to or
coordinating advertisers they can enjoy
substantially more revenue and higher
profit margins it's a win-win scenario
and if you're not convinced by potential
financial savings or better user
experience or more privacy i think you
should strongly consider the savings in
time
while all the benefits we've discussed
so far are definitely valuable the deal
breaker for me personally is definitely
time most people rarely consider time as
a currency which is a shame given that
it's the most valuable currency we have
and when we use free services the
currency that we're often paying with is
time again this isn't that important if
you barely use free services for example
if you only spend 20 minutes on youtube
every day it's not a big deal but i know
a lot of us spend six seven nine hours
on youtube every single day myself
included if we're not working or
socializing we're probably watching
youtube and nowadays the standard on
youtube has become two five second
non-skippable ads roughly every three
minutes
this means that for every hour you spend
on youtube you're consuming 45 second
ads or 200 seconds worth of ads if you
watch three hours worth of youtube on a
daily basis you're consuming 600 seconds
worth of ads every day and 18 000
seconds worth of ads every month that's
the same as 5 hours worth of ads every
single month youtube premium's
individual plan costs 12 per month this
means that by choosing to watch ads
instead of paying for youtube premium
you're effectively selling your time for
two dollars and 40 cents per hour and
that's if you're being stupid with your
subscription the smarter play is to
obviously get the family plan and split
it with your friends family and or
roommates the family plan costs 18 per
month and allows you to add up to five
members onto the plan this means that
each member is effectively paying just
three dollars per month considering this
by choosing to watch ads you're
effectively selling your time for 60
cents per hour even if you're just
watching one hour worth of youtube per
day you're selling your time for one
dollar and 80 cents per hour if you're
watching six hours per day you're
looking at 30 cents per hour and if
you're watching nine hours per day
you're looking at just 20 cents per hour
i don't think i need to explain why
these are unfavorable trade-offs and
similar arguments can be made if you
spend your time scrolling through tock
or instagram instead by using these free
services you're not only selling your
time for laughable amounts of money but
you're spending hours every month
watching ads instead of watching the
content itself
if you thought sacrificing your privacy
your user experience and your time were
not already bad enough you're also
sacrificing your position as a customer
for example take a look at these actions
a few years ago youtube moved away from
edgy content last year robin hood halted
trading on gamestop and just a few
months ago youtube removed the dislike
button all of these actions were
strongly disapproved of by users and
made users feel like these companies
weren't listening to their customers but
in reality all of these companies were
listening to their customers and swiftly
taking action the problem is that you're
not the customer with youtube
advertisers are the customer and they
wanted less edgy content and with
robinhood the market makers were the
customers and they weren't fans of
gamestop in both of these cases even
though you're a user you're actually a
product being sold now imagine if
everyone watching youtube had a youtube
premium subscription do you think
youtube would have removed the dislike
button or moved away from edgy content
no similarly if revenue customers paid a
commission on the trades like with the
traditional brokerage do you think
gamestyle would have been halted
probably not but by choosing to be the
product we give up all the power we
could have as a customer now look at the
flip side of the situation at companies
with extremely favorable reputations
probably one of the most admired
companies in the world is apple apple
does have their fair share of flaws when
it comes to overpricing and anti-repair
but apple receives virtually no
complaints regarding the quality of
their products or the quality of their
services or the user experience or the
security of the devices or the privacy
that apple provides and this is because
with apple you're truly the customer the
same cannot be said about free to use
services
at the end of the day many companies
have flocked over to free to use models
because it gives them an extraordinary
reach this is truly awesome because it
has made great services accessible to
people all around the world and i
strongly believe that their net impact
on the world is way more positive than
negative with that being said though
there is no such thing as a free service
if you're not paying with cash you're
paying with data and a time which is
often times much more expensive so i
think companies should offer more paid
options that allow users to become
customers not only would this be more
profitable for companies but it would
allow them to earn a much better
reputation do you really think that
google wants to be infamous for
collecting data when sergey brin and
larry page founded google their slogan
was literally don't be evil so i
strongly believe that every company
would prefer to directly deal with their
users the problem is that there isn't
enough interest from us for companies to
take this option more seriously so in
the end the choice comes down to us do
we want to remain a product or would we
rather become the customer where do you
guys stand on the spectrum comment that
down below also drop a like if this
video made you look at the situation
with big tech differently and of course
consider checking out our international
channels to watch the videos in other
languages and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you